ja und wir wollen ihnen herr lambsdorff
jetzt noch einmal ein foto zeigen ein
ganz aktuelles von donald trump hier
sieht man ihn mit der make america great
käppi und wenn ich das richtig sehe ist
da auch noch eine zahl dann ja wie gehen
sie mit diesem foto um was glauben sie
was was was löst das in den aus wenn sie
donald trump da jetzt so sehen das foto
löst in mir nicht so viel aus
donald trump ist der 45 präsident der
vereinigten staaten er ist das noch bis
ende januar nächsten jahres dann kommt
der 46 präsident diese republik gibt es
seit 240 jahren die hat schon viele
höhen und tiefen erlebt meistens
glücklicherweise haben wir deutschen
auch enorm von profitiert das darf man
nicht vergessen
wir verdanken den amerikanern genau wie
den russen auch unsere wiedervereinigung
sollte man vielleicht auch nicht
vergessen
aber was ich bei donald trump als person
und in seiner amtszeit und in seinem
regierungshandeln sehe ist das was peter
beyer gerade erwähnt hat er hat
tatsächlich in der amerikanischen
gesellschaft breiten rückhalt und es ist
nicht auszuschließen dass jemand wie er
vielleicht sogar er selber jemand aus
seiner familie in vier jahren antritt
und versucht diesen rückhalt noch einmal
zu mobilisieren und es ist eine politik
die sich damit verbindet die eben für
die demokratie gefährlich ist und das
ist das was mich eigentlich bewegt wird
es gelingen die notwendige die richtige
demokratische auseinandersetzung um die
besten lösungen für das land ist eine
art und weise zu führen dass die
demokratie keinen schaden nimmt und das
ist genau das problem das war aber
donald trump nicht der fall
er hat die auseinandersetzung so geführt
dass die demokratie beschädigt wurde
und das ist glaube ich etwas worauf wir
sehr genau achten müssen und deswegen
sagen wir auch als fdp wir müssen
amerika besser verstehen wir brauchen
eine neue transatlantische politik wir
brauchen mehr engagement mit amerika
wenn ich die spd heute höre die sagt wir
müssen uns einfach von amerika abkoppelt
und alles alleine machen das genau der
falsche weg wir müssen was aufbauen aber
nicht uns abkoppeln und das wir aufbauen
müssen ist ein besseres verständnis
dieses landes in dem so viele doch
jemand wie dort
und eben unterstützen mehr nachrichten
und breaking news nur bei bate schau
dich hier das nächste video an und
vergiss nicht zu abonnieren